when you're talking about you know
things that you look back in the past
and you shame yourself and you're like
oh I did this I'm a bad person I'm I
regret that I it's all these things and
when you start talking about them you
realize like we don't we're not born
into this world and we just are all
perfect we're all flawed and that's just
a reality and you are going to do things
that you know you look back and you go
oh my God if anybody knew that they
would think I'm just not a nice person
or if I'm not but you know you're it's
all about the end game right like if you
evolve that's the goal is to evolve to
not be that's the win that's the win so
you know if you know I was a certain way
when I was younger it's it's not who I
become today and who I'm becoming